bonjour à tous aujourd'hui c'est un jour
de rupture je quitte dj hype et je vais
vous dire pourquoi il ya un an le 15
décembre 2016 lorsque j'ai lancé mes
vidéos j'ai fait le choix de l'équipe et
avec un autre monde plus de dj hype pour
tourner nos soins plus c'est ma caméra
cachée en train de filmer tout de suite
c'est un peu un jour ne s'est par
ailleurs tristesse je t'en dire au
revoir
anna caméra et je change pour plusieurs
raisons alors dès le départ je tiens à
vous rassurer dj j'adore c'est une super
marque les produits sont fades le mélo
ce mot plus pour ce que je suis arrivé
un pot de vin politique par rapport au
travail que je fais sur la chaîne
youtube alors pas sur l'ensemble des
vidéos mais sur une partie est justement
je tenais à vous le dire parce que je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui peut
intéresser pas mal de youtube heures pas
mal de personnes qui ont une chaîne qui
lance une chaîne qui se posent des
questions quant à acheter l'eau snow
l'osm au plus et à savoir si c'est
intéressant ou jusqu'où on peut aller
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire donc c'est
pour ça que je vais vous faire un petit
peu ce retour d'expérience après avoir
passé un an complet avec ce matériel là
pour vous la faire très courte je vous
présente le matériel j'ai donc l'osm
opus qui est posée là sur un pied chez
donc un pied un trépied j'ai donc ce
qu'on appelle l'extortion rhodes qui est
posée sur le tripode tak tak l'osmose
d'attaché pour la victoire des départs
contraints d'acheter un micro j'ai
acheté celui ci le vidéo micro de rhodes
qui est bien mais il faut vraiment être
très proche dès lors vous êtes loin le
son est pas terrible à vous tenez votre
ce mot la main vous vous baladez vous
avez le micro qui est posée juste à côté
là c'est bien parce que vous n'êtes pas
trop s à 4 sinon c'est la galère alors
pour les prisons studio moi ce que je
conseille qui coûte beaucoup moins cher
c'est un petit micro comme seul à coucou
qui marche super bien et qui est
vraiment super sinon j'en ai un autre
quand je suis en extérieur c'est celui
ci ce micro drogue dont j'ai fait une
vidéo sur les micros
pour vous les présenter ça c'est bien
donc j'ai fait le choix de prendre le
micro là qui est bien maintenant lorsque
vous posez votre caméra un peu plus loin
vous êtes à distance tout de suite le
son est pas génial d'ailleurs j'ai fait
une vidéo de présentation avec une
interview de bosch marques comme super
solution d'ailleurs allez voir c'est ici
le micro est un peu loin on perd en
précision alors ça marche quand même
mais voilà ça c'est aussi une des
contraintes techniques qui m'a fait
changer de micro sa pensée micro qui
vendu avec rot avec le lot ce modèle
départ alors il ya des types
d'accessoires en plus j'ai acheté le
bâtiment vous le monter sur un vélo vous
accrocher ici votre trop ce mot c'est
pas génial parce que la tête même si
elle est stabilisée je trouve que quand
ça prend des chocs tue pas hyper fan je
préfère le nexium cannes pour moi ça
fait plus le job que cet accessoire de
chez dj alors après tels que on a
d'autres qui l'ont utilisée et qui ont
vraiment trouvé le produit fabuleux bon
moi je suis pas très peu sur ma faim est
là dessus ensuite vont une batterie plus
ça c'est un petit peu obligatoire ça ça
doit être le micro d'origine je pense
mon l'accessoire pour recharger voilà
voilà à partir d'un kit up mon kit de
base vont house voilà peu mon groupe de
base de mon osmo la différence entre
l'osm au plus c'est l'osmose c'est
qu'avec l'offre des grandes différences
avec l'asmo plus d'avoir vu un écart de
50 cm pour avoir un point de n'être avec
l'osm aux gens qu'il faut 1 m 56 je dis
pas de bêtises c'est pour ça qu'il faut
aussi notre mot plus il est un peu plus
cher mais franchement il est bien la
caméra est correct la stabilisation elle
est juste géniale légumes beaulieu
hausse de dj à se re extraordinaire si
vous l'avez vu déjà sur les drogues sont
les ma vie que ce soit les symptômes 4
en top 3 en finlande
la stab elle est vraiment génial non si
vous cherchez un super gameboy avec une
super stabilisation pour moi l'osm au
plus c'est de la balle déjà lorsque je
filme avec ou des bus filmé avec une
colorimétrie de base
maintenant je suis passé en mode log le
monologue du sein c'est très con dessus
mais ça me paraît vraiment d'avoir une
image très plate et de pouvoir après
requête une colorimétrie le monologue de
l'eau ce mot est bien
mais c'est pas encore complètement ça
mais après ça marche bien il ya rien à
dire de l'autre côté et là on est sur un
produit qui est aujourd'hui vendu par dj
hi han modèle nullos non plus à moins de
700 euros dont bon y'a rien à dire
là-dessus
le vrai problème que je rencontre c'est
que je suis amené de plus en plus me
déplacer pour la chaîne youtube j'étais
à berlin il ya pas longtemps j'étais
aussi rencontrer des créateurs high tech
des entrepreneurs par le biais de la
french state of je bouge pas mal et du
fait de devoir bouger
j'ai un vrai problème avec ça c'est à
dire que lorsque j'ai besoin de
l'allumer rapidement pour tourner un
sujet parce que je vais capter un
instant qui est intéressant qu'il faut
aller vite et bien là l'osm au plus où
l'osm au fond pas du tout le job c'est à
dire que je dois l'allumer il salue
ensuite j'allume mon smartphone je dois
trouver le réseau wifi je trouve mon
réseau wifi je me connecte je sors je
vais sûrement d'applications une femme
je sors mon application il faut que
j'aille sur le mode vidéo sur le mode
vidéo lors on imagine ans que ma carte
et ainsi pas besoin de l'avis dès que
tout soit calé calibre et une fois que
je suis ferme en mode vidéo
je fais mon point pour effectivement
avoir la netteté sur la chose que je
veux filmer je positionne mon os mots je
filme et j'ai perdu entre 30 à 40 45
secondes
et si vous avez beaucoup de wifi il faut
vous trouviez le tout le vote réseau
permis de faire cesser rapidement
contraignant s'est rapidement pénible
c'est un peu pour moi
une des limites de ce produit après
l'autre limite c'est qu'effectivement
vous avez une caméra qui est bien qu'ils
aient une bonne qualité mais on n'est
pas non plus sur un outil professionnel
alors c'est à dire que enfin de faire
dire ce qu'est ce que je dis pas pour
moi c'est une super cave
mais lorsqu'on veut aller plus loin en
colorimétrie en qualité d'image qu'on a
besoin d'un petit outil rapide
fonctionnel c'est un peu la limite de ce
produit c'est un peu voilà aujourd'hui
le problème que je rencontre pour
solutionner ce problème
j'ai cherché des caméras qui était sympa
qui pouvait marcher je suis allé voir du
côté de chez cannon le 90 qui est une
référence et qui est très connu mais
fondamentalement il ya aussi un problème
à 90 c'est que vous n'avez pas le mode
blog pour avoir une image complètement
flat et vous n'avez pas une
stabilisation cinq axes la stabilisation
cinq axes on la trouve sur le 77 des
déjà présenté d'ailleurs j'ai fait une
petite vidéo si vous avez parce qu'il ya
longtemps dans la scène un peu évolué
depuis mais c'est une vidéo dessus 77
des à bien la stabilisation cinq axes
mais par contre pas de mode log dont bon
et ça peut compliquer je veux voir du
côté de chez panasonic le g h 4 à le
mode log faut rajouter 100 euros de plus
en option pour l'avoir mais on peut la
voir
par contre il n'ya pas de stabilisation
cinq axes si je veux un super capteurs
un superbe boîtier une stabilisation
cinq axes et pouvoir avoir un mode blog
j'ai une espèce de problématiques un peu
un peu un peu compliqué et j'ai trouvé
ma solution
et justement j'ai fait fumer la carte
bleue je ne suis pas sponsorisé ça
j'étais avec mon argent
est-ce que je vais sortir je les payais
mon argent aussi donc c'est de la pub
pour personne mais par contre c'est
vraiment la solution pour moi idéal par
rapport à ma problématique faisait
acheter le gh5 de chez panasonic
alors c'est pas un produit qui cadeau
cadeaux mais par contre il a vraiment
pour moi un cahier des charges
extraordinaires
c'est aujourd'hui une des références
pour faire de la vidéo je connais
énormément de vidéastes j'ai eu que des
retours positifs du gh1 qu'alors chacun
à son modèle préféré il y en a qui sont
plus chez sony docce canyon de chez
panasonic
peu importe chez nikon aussi faim parce
tous tous les citer mais panasonic gh5
pour l'avoir vu l'avoir déjà testé avoir
eu énormément de retours des personnes
qui font du broadcast c'est vraiment un
produit qui est super et moi par rapport
à ma problématique personnelle j'ai une
stabilisation cinq axes ce qui fait que
je peux te dire à la main déplacer elle
pose un endroit
j'aurai toujours une certaine
stabilisation alors après c'est pas
aussi bien qu'un d'ingall ou si bien
qu'un adossement plus mais la
stabilisation franchement elle est top
et a fait vraiment bien le job
et là dessus je peux avoir un mode
vailog alors pour avoir levé log
j'ai dû débourser un peu plus d'argent
s'en fiche c'est juste pour dire que
même si l'appareil est quand même un des
produits qui pak à lugano il faut
rajouter un peu plus pour la barre alors
ce qu'on va faire c'est que ce produit
j'ai voulu présenter dès demain on va
faire un dock si on a regardé ce qui à
l'intérieur puis on va le présenter
faire une prise en main l'allumé bord un
peu l'objectif lorsque je le maîtrisais
vraiment que j'aurais vraiment me ebah
ce moment là je vous ferai une vidéo
plus complète pour vous présenter cet
appareil surtout côté vidéo moi la photo
c'est pas trop mon job la vidéo ça l'est
davantage
donc on fera un tour au dessus voilà un
petit peu pourquoi aujourd'hui jeudi die
by dj hi sur ce produit alors dj je
pense que j'irai sur d'autres produits
sains des drones des choses comme ça tel
que je prendrai un os mobile pour avoir
une telle solution stabiliser pour film
avec mon portable qui pourrait être
super mais maintenant en caméra
principale va y avoir du changement 10 h
5 de chez panasonic
d'ailleurs si ça vous intéresse 1 le
complète à vendre donc
je vous laisse me mettre un commentaire
en nous envoyant un email hello @
monsieur gros point fr ça vous intéresse
on m'a quelques messages
et puis dont voici que je peux faire
ensemble dites moi ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que vous avez vous déjà des
produits qui a dit jerry est ce que vous
avez un os snow and osmo plus est ce que
vous pilotez les drones dites moi ce que
vous en pensez en terme d'image et puis
est ce que comme moi vous sentez un
moment un peu les limites du produit pas
par rapport au produit en lui-même et
par rapport à votre utilisation et par
rapport à ce que vous en cherchez
est-ce que vous avez déjà essayé ces
petits bijoux
est-ce que vous avez déjà 10 h 4 qui est
un super appareil vous mettez tout sans
commentaire on n'en pas et vous allez
voir qu'il va y avoir encore du
changement encore des surprises
le fait d'avoir un produit qui est plus
compact avec une meilleure porte
activités je peux déplacer jalu touch
peut shooter on va faire des choses top
on va faire des choses un peu
différentes par rapport à tout ce qu'on
a fait ces derniers temps sur la chaîne
de langue vous inquiétez pas on va
garder la même trame un tour paris de
high-tech mais on va aller se balader un
peu à droite à gauche on va essayer de
faire un peu du développent des galas la
plein plein plein de possibilités pense
qu'on va bien se marrer
vous mettez tout ça en commentaire on en
discute ensemble je vous remercie vous
invite à laisser des gens y pousse à
vous abonner
parce qu'on parlera toujours toujours et
toujours et encore mieux de high tech
merci à vous soyez sages je vous
embrasse et je vous dis à très vite pour
faire un tour de ce panasonic jeu 5 15